What else do you recall from your breakfast?
Hamilton?
I ate it from a ceramic bowl with a metal fork.
Optimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Posting a question.
Now
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue,
so
this episode is brought to you by inc tell and I've used them personally ever
since I wrote the four hour work week.
I've been asked over and over again how I choose to delegate tasks,
how I do 80 20 analysis and so on.
At the root of many of those decisions is a simple question.
Actually two questions.
Number one,
how can I invest money to improve my quality of life?
I use that in investing as well.
The second,
how can I spend a little money or moderate money to save significant time inc
tell is one of those investments there a turnkey solution for all of your
imaginable customer care needs?
I used ink tell during the launch of the four hour body,
which was very,
very involved and they provided 24 seven customer service for my land rush
campaign because it was critical for me to take care of every person who
purchased my books and participated.
This allowed me to focus on the things that I am better at,
my strengths,
like the marketing plan that we'd worked on for six months,
implementing that until trains their experience.
Customer service reps to know your business and your products inside and out and
make it your customers are raving fans.
They answer more than a million customer service requests every year and they
can do so across all platforms including email,
phone,
social media,
texts,
even chat,
leaving your customers with poor service or just mediocre service,
which by the way,
in a competitive pool is a huge liability.
Long wait times are unanswered messages carries a massive cost and risk to your
business.
Ink Tell removes the logistics and headaches of this type of communication,
allowing you to focus on your strengths and grow your business.
It can be a real competitive advantage.
And I see many,
many ecommerce companies and tech companies thinking of customer service as a
good enough checkbox or an afterthought,
and it just like airbnb use design and innovative ways to be a competitor and to
win.
You can do the same thing with customer service.
So as a listener of this podcast,
you can get up to $10,000 off.
That's a big discount.
$10,000 off your startup fees and costs by visiting intel.com forward slash.
Tim So check it out.
For more info,
go to [inaudible] Dot com I N K t e l.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by leadership in turbulent times,
which is the latest book by the Ever Amazing Pulitzer Prize winning author,
Doris Kearns Goodwin.
I had her on the podcast not too long ago and she just blew everyone away.
What an incredible storyteller and weaver of history and lessons from history.
You can check that out if you want a tim.blog forward slash.
Doris D.
R I.
S.
It was a captivating conversation that that really blew me away.
Leadership and turbulent times.
That is the latest book is a culmination of five decades of a claim studies in
presidential history,
which offers an illuminating exploration of the early development.
That's super key.
Early Development,
growth and exercise of leadership and uh,
draws upon four presidents,
which we'll get to in a second.
Goodwin asks and answers in those pages.
The questions are leaders born or made,
where does ambition come from?
How does adversity affect the growth of leadership?
Does the leader make the times or do the times make the leader?
And she draws upon the four presidents she has studied most closely,
namely Abraham Lincoln Theater,
Roosevelt,
Franklin d,
Roosevelt and Lyndon B Johnson to show and how they recognize leadership
qualities within themselves and were recognized as leaders by others.
And I mentioned early development being key because it goes back to their first
soldier as an experiments and attempts at engaging with policy and public life
and covers their failures,
their near misses and lessons learned.
So it applies to anyone who is trying to make a study of leadership or how they
can better lead both themselves and others.
It's important to underscore that no common pattern describes completely a
single trajectory of leadership,
although set apart in background abilities and temperament.
These four men shared a fierce ambition and deep seated resilience that enabled
them to surmount uncommon hardships and at their best all four were guided by a
sense of moral purpose.
This seminal work provides an accessible and essential roadmap for aspiring and
established leaders in every field.
I highly,
highly recommend it.
For more information,
you can visit Doris Kearns,
goodwin.com that's Doris Kearns,
k e a r n S.
goodwin.com and leadership in turbulent times is available in hardcover ebook
and audio wherever books are sold.
Check it out.
I know boys and girls,
ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Today's guest,
I'm going to keep this intro short and skip the preamble because I'm so excited
to share this with you.
Is Hamilton Morris on Twitter at Hamilton Morris Instagram at Hamilton Morris,
who is a writer,
documentarian and scientific researcher who currently studies the chemistry and
pharmacology of tryptamines.
What are those?
We'll talk about it at the University of the sciences in Philadelphia.
His writing has been featured and Harper's playboy and vice and he is the
creator of the television series and oh my goodness,
do I love it?
Hamilton's Pharmacopia are Pharmacopia Cha.
You don't have to worry about spelling.
It's easy to find as soon as you type in Hamilton's Pharma anywhere that you
want to find it,
whether that's Amazon prime or wherever,
which recently completed its second season and it is absolutely one of my
favorite series of the last five years.
I don't know how on earth it took me so long to find this.
It's fantastic and I encourage you to check it out.
His website,
which should be up by the time this episode publishes.
I'm going to keep prodding him is Hamilton morris.com Hamilton,
as you'd think,
m o R R I s.com and this episode goes into the chemistry of psychedelics and
mind altering substances,
his adventures and misadventures or around the world with different indigenous
cultures,
different clandestine chemists,
and all sorts of characters.
Very,
very smart guy.
Exceptionally good at explaining complex subjects simply and making science
sexy.
Please meet Hamilton Morris
Hamilton.
Welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me.
I have been hoping to have this conversation on the podcast ever since I first
saw your show and have recommended the show too.
Probably more people than any other show I've seen in the last three to five
years.
So thank you for making it,
first of all.
That's great.
I'm glad you like it.
And I wanted to begin the conversation and we're going to bounce around a lot.
I will mispronounce many,
many things,
so please pardon my ignorance.